good morning welcome to the 15th ftth
conference and the beautiful city of
Valencia it is my great pleasure to
welcome all of you today morning your
excellency our distinguished plenty
potential ease ladies and gentlemen
colleagues and friends
what place could be better to discuss
technology policies driving fiber
investments and the financing aspect of
fiber networks then the country of Spain
which is a front-runner in fiber
deployment as well as digitalization it
is my great honor to welcome our
openings keynote speaker
His Excellency Alvaro Nadal the Spanish
Minister for energy tourism and the
Digital Agenda Don Alvaro Nadal please
join me on stage to deliver your opening
keynote
[Applause]
good morning to everyone and welcome to
to Valencia here to Spain and thank you
for allowing me to to to start to
narrate this conference which is one of
the main issues in order to develop a
digital agenda when the ministry and
this legislative term was changed its
name from telecommunication to Digital
Agenda everybody told me why why this
change because this is not about
telecommunication networks anymore
telecommunication networks are key in
the developing of the sector and the
technology and the whole change in
civilization that's going on and in this
21st century but this is not the only
point so if you allow me I can tell you
what do we think pure digital agenda
should be and then we go down to
infrastructure which is this Congress
about a first point is of course
infrastructure we need to develop an
infrastructure without infrastructure we
don't have anything at all it's like
trying to have the automobile industry
without roads it's clear you are experts
in this matter much better than me but
it is true that we don't have only an
automobile industry with roads we need
much more than that so the great
challenges of our society is not only to
develop infrastructure in a in a right
way in an adequate work way but also to
have an industry and to make the rest of
the sectors to participate in the
digital revolution which is not easy at
all so what can we do in order to foster
digital industry as always saying once
we've got infrastructure and we I will
tell you later on of what we are doing
in the Spanish government for
infrastructure and how the Spanish model
has been very successful but once we've
got this restructure how do we well how
do we develop and digital industry and I
think we've got two important
bottlenecks especially here in Europe
and especially here in Spain one is
financing we don't have a model of
financing of the digital industry that
deals with risk pools risk in the
way we would like it to have we good you
go to banks usually banks what do they
do
it's just to provide loans and mortgages
we need something else something totally
different and here in Europe we need a
big push but change of how we need to
finance the whole change the whole
revolutionary change in the digital
sector second is Education and Skills we
need many more people learning maths
learning physics learning chemistry this
kind of typical scientific subjects that
are going to be the key for the workers
not only in the near future right now in
Europe only two of its five high school
students as to the study pure science
it's not a great number we need many
more and we need to foster new ideas and
new services I mean people are very
clever governments don't make the
innovations we are low for innovations
but we don't make the reverse but we can
help for example we can change the way
public services are carried out
yesterday it was with the Ministry of
minister of employment and the Deputy
Prime Minister and the minister of
social issues developing a new social
cart is going to be totally digital and
it's going to have in there all the
different subsidies and aids that all
different administrations are given to a
certain person are going to have a map a
real-time map for the first time of all
sorts of all sorts of social subsidies
and helped that we are providing to the
people this is very new and it's going
to allow us a lot how to do for example
we are working at the Ministry of
Tourism to think how to improve the
knowledge about tourists in Spain in
Spain it's a you know it's a tourism
superpower second in the world ok but we
want to know where the people come from
we still have some people mains making
service in the airports well we've got
the Rome in that roaming that is very
useful to know what people are doing
where they come from what do they visit
so it's a huge
that's going on we need to think about
data and to regulate properly data so
first point we need to do many things in
order to foster this digital sector and
these digital platforms secondly how do
we make other sectors understand the
importance of the digital revolution and
this is very important as well I think
we need social political and media tech
focus is the most important thing
somebody does do in I don't know
steel or manufacturing cars they know
what they what they do because they
aren't thinking about the connected car
but many other industries perhaps the
olive oil I don't care
they all must think that there is a wide
range of possibilities out there to
improve their production they have to
reach there to their clients how to
improve logistics and I think it's more
a matter of having lot of focus from the
political side from the mediatic science
from the social side on the idea that we
are in the middle of a revolution so
important or even more important that
what happened for example 100 years ago
with electricity third point which i
think is very important the digital
revolution is changing our way of life
in the sense that we need to think very
wide in order to protect our
constitutional and civil rights intimacy
has changed a lot with net totally how
do we protect that our children how do
we protect them now because all our
constitutions are analog they're not
digital so we need to think how to
change the important rules the base
rules of our societies in order to
protect the our individual rights in the
same way as we have inflecting them in
the in the analog time for some of IANS
pain we have created a group of experts
lawyers sociologists technologists
thinking about how do we protect our our
rights as we have had been protecting
them and another very important point
now cyber security
it's as important in the security of a
country as the normal police service has
been in the past in the digital world we
need a lot of effort coming from cyber
security and we need to make people
understand they in the same way that
they lock occur or their houses they
need to protect their computers and
their smartphones and this is also very
important as well and a whole change
that's going on but probably not that
they say added at the right pace we need
to be faster in this taxation if you go
to the vit directive in the European
Union they say that the text must be
paid when the physical good is given to
a customer come on in the digital world
how does it work
makes no sense direct and indirect
taxation probably will have to change
dramatically in this technological in
this digital revolution I think more or
less this could be the whole bunch of
ideas we should have in a digital agenda
at European level at national level I'm
talking about European level because of
many of our competence are shared in the
European Union but going down to
infrastructure which is the key as I was
saying before it's important to know
that we should be asking I mean when
they say we everybody the society in
general we should be asking all
political powers to invest in digital
infrastructure more than the what is
asked for for example transport
infrastructure I am Minister I go here
to Valencia probably will listen so many
business people telling me that they
want a new road there they want to
enlarge the airport somewhere else or
they want a new port somewhere else
of course transport infrastructure is
important but right now digital
infrastructure is much more important
than transport infrastructure much more
and by the way much less expensive for
the cost of 100 kilometres of high alpha
high-speed train we can we can improve
between 10 and 15 percentage points
the coverage of fiber in a country so
it's quite a deal for a political point
of view it's quite a deal and it allows
people to reach possibilities Digital
possibilities that they couldn't imagine
before and it's also a way of allowing
sparse dispersed remote areas to have
the same level of services and the same
standard of living as high-density areas
and it's also a way to reduce the
economic differences because it allows
people from anywhere to work and and to
and to participate in the most important
and advanced and growing and high
growing sectors in the economy so
infrastructure is key and you are doing
the cornerstone of the system it's not
as I was saying before just with
infrastructure we won't have the best
digital revolution but simple impossible
to have the best digital revolution
without that infrastructure in the case
of Spain as you know we have covered
with last generation networks fibre
mainly 85% of our population
right now our goal is to go as fast as
possible to 100% or at least to 100
percent of all villages in the country
and this is therefore we are trying to
make why have been why Spain has been
able to develop that so rapidly and so
widely I think that remain reasons first
a good regulation which is not only a
stable and for civil regulation for a
law allowing for investment but also
removing bottlenecks and obstacles in
the regulation whatever operators need
to develop the infrastructure we provide
them with that for example here in Spain
we allow operators to go from Fischetti
to facade of an era of any house
with no restriction at all they are
allowed to that will remove any kind of
problems they might have with property
rights or with with urbanism rules or
regulations things like that secondly
which is very important we as government
having in the past not only now in the
past as well we haven't been very greedy
when we were have been asking operators
especially when they were buying a
spectrum for for wireless networks we
didn't ask too much money but in
exchange of that we asked for regulatory
obligations to develop networks so you
are going to keep as operator your money
in your pocket but you need to invest
that in new in you networks and invest
properly better with that that that done
simply the trench so it allows for rapid
development and a low cost and at that
same time while we were developing
transport infrastructures we were
forcing all operators in the transport
networks to allow and to develop fiber
which is also important it has allowed
to create a quite dense grid a quite
dense network for in the mind in the
main lines of the of this fiber
development or deployment and third we
have been using public money which is
important as well market cannot provide
enough demand for a full development on
infrastructure understanding that this
is like it was electricity 100 years ago
only to those parts were demand allowed
for development of electricity grids
would have left a big part of the
country without electricity but al
tricity sooner or later was going to
become a first need item good and at the
same time was going to become vital for
any production or consumption activity
so sooner or later you will have to
develop that infrastructure
that happens the same with fiber fiber
and of course a high-speed digital
networks are going to be needed
everywhere so the sooner we start the
better and if we do it efficiently at a
low cost then there is no excuse at all
not to develop them and that's what we
think as government and then it comes
another important point we have reached
at a moment and I think you will agree
with that knowing more than me because
I'm not a technological expert in which
there is no such a thing as a division
between fixed networks and wireless
networks now they are symbiotic with 5g
their symbiotic so it's impossible some
people might have the temptation to
think okay I don't need to invest that
much in fees networks because I will
have the possibility to develop 5g
that's nonsense and we know all that
they will have to be developed at the
same time and one helps to the other
because we are talking about if we are
thinking about the highway is changing
from four lanes to how many four hundred
links because what's going to happen
it's a total change in the technology
it's a total change of possibilities and
probably we don't know how we are going
to use this broadband capacity the
developments are started right now we
can have some intuition of what might
happen but the energy as now we are
going to be amazed of what's going to
change because the possibilities are
huge
the more we enlarge demand the more
application services and ideas come and
the most badly needed then is that kind
of infrastructure so I'm very happy to
be here because I think we are talking
about the future we are talking about
what's going and it's already changing
the world and it's the base of the
system and we need to be very sensitive
in our public policy about this very
very sensitive because the future of all
our nation's is linked to what how we
are going to do
so well or bad in this technological
revolution main actors of today were the
successful actors in the former
technological revolutions and as I was
saying before infrastructure is the
cornerstone is were over that
infrastructure we build the rest so this
conference has all the I think all the
ingredients for success I like the
social focus that at least and mediatic
focus that this conference provides not
only here to Spain but to the rest of
the world and I'm very grateful to you
because being in politics we like to
talk about long-term issues and things
that really change society for the
better and you are doing that job thank
you very much
[Applause]
you